So here's our problem. If we try to see the amount
of users in each age group, it's not in order and
it's hard to compare immediately. This problem is even more noticeable
on a different plot. If we try to create the same
plot for users in each income bracket, we see a very
similar problem. And here it's much worse. These first two bins
are for a 100,000 and over 150,000. And this last bin
is for people who make under 20,000. Our eyes tend to read
pages from left to right, so this graph is pretty hard to
interpret. Or even better said, it'd be very hard to make comparisons
naturally with our eye. We have to always scan down to the
bottom to figure out what group we're in. So let's order the
factors in our age.range variable. What I want you to do is
to look up the documentation for the factor function. Or you can
read through the example that we've linked in the instructor notes. Once
you're ready, try to write the code in order to order the
levels of this variable. And just as a
reminder, the level should take on these values.